[Musique]
alors ça en est où ce procès avec vestas
heures l'incendié apparemment c'est
réglé qui est ce que gagner c'est nous
ah ben on dit quoi le morceau là
authentique parle des médias québécois
que je me marre de toutes ces choses qui
sont dites comme par exemple en disant
on pourrait croire que chaque langue
sans le cas pas du tout ce à quoi tous
les a priori de son fait tout simple et
10 dans vos mamans elles pensent quoi
donnons notre groupe sont semble abonder
gène pourrait on pas du tout un ami ça
mais aussi c'est une expression de
là-bas alors ça dérange pas pas la
première fois que tu es arrivé chez toi
tu as dis à ta mère je fais un groupe ça
s'appelait nique ta mère a joué pas dit
la première fois t'as pas osé un vous
êtes soutenu par jacques lang qu'il est
toujours du bien de boue ouais bah il
paraît si un jour on vous proposait de
faire l'arbre de noël à l'elysée vous
iriez les bonnes non mais d'abord on
n'est pas soutenu par jacques lang quoi
c'est une subvention qu'il a offert
quand on propose de l'argent être encore
soirée apprend sinon je ne connais pas
personnellement j'avais alors l'arbre de
noël à l'elysée non pourquoi flins ouais
j'sais pas imagine qu'ils ont envie de
faire plaisir
un énorme merci à 9 ans le jeune homme
j'en donne plein jour ce placard au soir
ne pas leur rentrer dedans il me donne
les pistes pour un bon tu le gardes
ouais bon merci merci joey starr
joey starr bonsoir vous êtes ici pour la
sortie d'un single qui s'appelle gazelle
et qui figure sur la bande son du film
astérix et obélix mission cléopâtre
d'alain chabat
vous savez comment fait que les petites
mains joey pour faire croire à
pour faire quoi montre les baffes et
alors qu'en expliqué joe et en même
temps tu as une bague et nantes auteur
d'un gros pain dans ta gueule qu'est ce
que tu veux mon grand
[Musique]
monsieur le
promis
il a menti
[Musique]
fois extrait de la bande originale du
film d'alain chabat astérix et obélix
mission cléopâtre alors alain chabat est
un vrai fan de vous en l'an 2000 avait
fait un documentaire qui s'appelait
authentique réalisé par lui et sa rb6
stefan bellof way d'ailleurs vous deviez
jouer dans le film astérix et vous
deviez jouer le rôle de nick la police
mais vous a fait vous êtes disparu du
scénario à la quatrième version pourquoi
vous étiez en taule au moment du
tournage n'ont même pas non même pas non
alors il y a un an sortait une
compilation des remixes de ntm
ça a été un vrai carton ça c'est
énormément vendu est aujourd'hui ntm est
un peu en stand by no way et emme est
une grosse machine et qu'à chaque fois
qu'on part pour faire une tournée pour
faire un six mois de promo à répéter
trois mois avant fin août à un truc à
chaque coup qu'on entrevoit les avec un
t aime ça promet toujours si ça lui mois
de préparation ou autre et ça nous
permettait pas de faire ce qu'on avait
envie de faire à côté quoi donc ces 10
cas là on va essayer quand même alors
vous avez quand même vendu 2 millions de
disques avec ntm et ça fait quatre ans
car rien ne ferait qu est sorti est ce
que est ce que c'est pour toujours ou
vous pensez rebeuss et avec kool shen
ntm on met toujours quoi 80 faire
l'album dans les traits de dakhla alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes façon en fait même
si ça prend son sens garde connu ouais
aujourd'hui vous vivez à saint-ouen dans
une communauté hip hop dans un pavillon
il ya tout votre bande qu'émilie la pop
hip hop non on n'est pas des beatniks
en vie en collectivité mais auquel on y
notait alors vous dites certaines nuits
on se retrouve à 50 alors cessé
d'envoyer votre studio un enregistrement
et puis aussi vous faites votre émission
pour skyrock
voilà le jeudi ça s'appelle jeudi jour
de ces demies le samedi s'appellent mais
ta femme à l'abri ça vous emmerde d'être
devenu un des uns des personnages comme
ça des français vit dans un monde h
intrinsèque donc ça m'intéresse très peu
quoi ouais mais bon je subis quoi ouais
vous êtes médiatique maintenant ouais je
crois pensez quoi de la caricature qui
font de vous les guignols qu'est ce que
j'en pense marquant c'est une rolls n'
roll invite à côté ou avec 93 le sport
national c'est quand la chambre est donc
donc je n'ai pas de problème à ce qu'on
rigole deux mois qu'on attend que c'est
bien fait quoi voilà bien un joey starr
tout le monde vous connaît mais on vous
connaît peu on va parler de vous et de
votre vie
[Applaudissements]
alors votre vrai nom c'est didier
morville vous êtes né n'est pas la vraie
c'est quand même un nom didier morville
ouais c'est ça ah vous êtes né dans une
cité la seine-saint-denis wojtyla
derrière votre père assis l'irascible
comme comme amenant un mais conformes
ouais vous ai fait une chanson
d'ailleurs s'appelle laisse pas traîner
ton fils ouais pour lui parler ou enfin
j'écris une chanson parce que j'avais
faim je fais ce que j'ai donc après
après comme utiliser l'enfant mort pour
lui parler c'est un peu tard maintenant
ouais potes mais rossi vous l'avez
retrouvé assez tardivement ouais
regardez vous être regardée comme
toujours mal et pendant les repas de
famille quand on vous disait qu'est ce
que tu veux faire quand tu seras grand
bleu répondez quoi je répondais pas vu
j'avais pas vraiment d'idée donc voila
quoi elle en 82 vous avez un choc
vous avez 20 ans vous allez au trocadéro
et vous découvrez deux jeunes américains
qui danse le smurf au son d'un ghetto
blaster c'est le début du hip hop vous
rencontrez kool shen à ce moment là
qu'une chaîne en fait ils habitaient de
l'autre côté de l'avenue moi j'étais
d'un côté lui de l'autre donc c'était
déjà faire connaissiez avant moi j'étais
comme tous les banlieusards à l'époque
on montait sur paris désert on pourra la
voir ce que font les autres quoi ouais
mais quand vous dansiez tous les deux
dans le métro vous gagner du pognon non
ouais un petit peu au nord des miettes
sensible d'une heure et demie et sa mort
c'est bien gagner de la tune dans tous
les deux dans le métro châtelet les
halles les gens qui font la manche ça
marche bien ça ça ils subviennent quoi
ouais faut gagner plus que votre père
par exemple
non je faisais autre chose pour gagner
plus comme anglais alors en 84 donc
c'est la fin de l'émission de sydney est
en fait le graffiti remplace un peu le
smurf et la break dance dans le
mouvement hip hop c'est ça ouais le
graffiti c'est un truc en fait
enfin l'ami de kool shen d'avant un
livre d'histoire géographie qu'une toute
petite photo comme ça dans mes troupes
new york est un parti l'allemand quoi
ouais ouais on a commencé à pisser dans
les coins et puis après un soin les gens
alors au départ ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est can tm c'était un groupe de
tagguer en 86 avant d'être un groupe de
chanteurs et puis un jour vous
rencontrés disent trahis men et johnny
go et ils vous disent le taxer de la
merde c'est le rap qui est au top
vous affirmez enfin il essaie de les
expliquer qu on fait de la merde et koné
démerde c'est plus comme ça et nous ne
les prenions pas pourquoi grands n'ont
pas grand chose aussi à l'époque on
s'est dit si on va leur répondre et on a
été créé le premier texte dans la
cuisine de mon père de leur montrer que
l'on peut le faire nous aussi les gros
êtes vous dit à ce moment-là nous dans
le rap on va tout déchirer
et ça a donné ça
[Musique]
pour travailler
la charité nuit d'été
il est bon
avant que le boulot
j c
souvent
l'état quand on est soi-même en état
d'ébriété
fort mentalement retarder notre éthique
le prototype du pompier voilà pourquoi
dans l'excellent
c'est le voit l'amour
qu'en pensent les
la part de la mère patrie du pays
[Musique]
j'avais pas le plus
le couple est parti
[Musique]
pas figuré
celle ci doit spécifier la moins
commandes dans la ville de bam
boston
là
ma
[Musique]
quand j'allais au second tour par la
mairie
[Musique]
m
le monde
sur la corde à linge gaza
non orange la demande sur la bande
annonce
par le roi
[Applaudissements]
en fin de mois
mais qu'est ce qu'on attend pour ne plus
suivre les règles si je mettais
[Musique]
quand il ya ça
alors est ce que c'est vrai que votre
maison de disques epic vous a suggéré un
moment que ntm qui veut dire nique ta
mère
ça signifie le nord transmet le message
non jamais jamais moi je peux je peux
prétendre à un truc c'est que je peux
parti je crois des rares groupes thé du
seul groupe en france qu'à jamais
présenté une maquette avant de faire un
album quoi rien quoi souple ntm ça vous
plaît bien
franchement
parce qu'elle est tout seul parce
qu'elle est quoi mais tout ça n'est pas
mariée c'est ça c'est un bon parti moi
ici pensez quoi du rap français en
général
geste à bayard ap rap c'est comme tout
il ya vous mourrez humour ouais c'est
pas ça pour toi
enfin pour nous un peu parce que ce
qu'il a un côté caustique nous on est
des hooligans derrière qui fait bien de
prendre des pincettes parce que je peux
tu éclaté alors et ça c'est démesuré ton
propos parce que sa palette à l'italie
tout de suite la violence à la violence
voilà c'est un tuba voilà ça c'est
l'exemple même je trouve un peu trop
virulent pour la télé alors je disais ce
qui a été son papa la question cédera de
français c'est que je les dis akhenaton
il peut les toucher doc gynéco c'est du
plastique sans consistance
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas dire
finalement on fait un peu du gangsta rap
et que les autres font du rap normal moi
je suis pas gros ce temps là mais
gangsta rap ça veut dire qu'on a un
gangster obligatoirement bas un peu un
peu s'il ya marqué gangsters en rab
d'accord
la garda car je crois que moi je suis
plus dans un passé on doit constituer je
crois que dans une catégorie
ce constat d'une certaine urgence en
fait qu'on raconte développe kouame mais
en aucun cas je cherche à me faire
passer pour un bandit où je pense que
déjà déjà s'est moqué de respect aux
gens qui font ça et qui sont son coup
d'essai comme on dit nécessité fait loi
je pense qu'il ya des gens qui font ça
est faux pas le choix compagne d'autre
choix que pas d'autres août ils ont tout
pour pouvoir s'en sortir des cinq puis
ces gens là moi je les ai vus vivre je
sais ce que c'est ainsi donc par rapport
à ça j'ai aucun droit de me réclamer
gangster voix nue ou autres quoi je fais
de la musique
donc j'ai cette chance là quoi il est
pas très très chaud sur la france vous
avez déclaré le fn est dissous mais les
racistes reste assez mois qu'ils à wayne
je sais pas si je parle comme ça mais
allons-y
je sais pas on est toujours me direz
vous on est toujours dans le même pays
de collabo on a senti un drapeau qu'une
fois les américains arrivés d'ailleurs
en ce moment là qu'a regarder la tv
quand il s'est plaint de jeu je t'ai
lumine jeudi en coin de table a été
celui donc qui s'appelait quoi donc je
connais bien ozap il colle à bout quoi
qui moi je suis pas très problème c'est
que moi je viens dès fin mai par an
vient des colonies moi je suis né ici
quoi mais et puis on n'a pas oublié
qu'on est venu nous chercher et puis que
la france est un pays cosmopolite donc
donner moi j'ai 34 ans je paie beaucoup
d'impôts en fait encore sentir que je
suis pas forcément à ma place
quelque chose qui va pas quoi c'est déjà
ça le fait que j'ai une tête ramé ça
joue quoi est fait reste quoi tient le
sourire aussi le voir oui mais ça ça
c'est le sourire shine
quand je les vois je suis pas don t il
est vrai jamais rejoindre
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que j'ai l'impression joey starr
que malgré votre succès vous avez du mal
à vous sortir de la banlieue votre
enfance vous dit le sac à dos de la
banlieue il reste accroché à toi mon
univers il est là quoi je pense que si
on sort de ça je sais pas si j'ai encore
des outils pour eux
moi je je pense que je suis là parce
qu'il ya une raison d'être
je veux dire pas j'ai un média dans les
mains donc j'en profite pour présenter
comme je le peux la main la majorité
silencieuse donc c'est surtout ça en
fait on ne combat quoi
ouais j'habite encore là à côté parce
que notre ailleurs pour le moment quoi
bien j'ai besoin des miens surtout quoi
c'est à dire c'est mon essence quoi et
puis des fois
joey starr vous pétez un peu les plans
[Musique]
alors on va pas faire le listing de tous
vos ennuis avec la justice mais c'est
vrai que j'avais eu souvent l'occasion
de vous affronter à vos comptes en droit
non je vous affrontez une fois non ouais
mais fait peur j'arrive devant chez
j'arrive devant chez sony et puis je
sais puisque avait une entrevue que le
journal que je dirigeais à l'époque à
bout ça faisait plus qu'il y avait moi
je sais ce qu'il dirait moi j'étais avec
avec mon amie béatrice et puis des gens
nous ont sauté dessus et puis dans
l'entrevue j'ai vu ça un monde était
drogué un truc un autre super anodin
voire carrément il y avait une page
complète
sinon page complète avec deux lignes
devraient c'est à dire qu'on était dans
la rue béatrice et moi je suis ce qui
était vrai le reste était donc cinq
entrevues c'était des interviews donc
c'est l'interview du mec qui nous a bien
vers le maquis oui mais je pense que je
pense que quand même c'était le mec là
qui vous aviez ouvert le crâne qui
disait six mois il m'a ouvert le crâne
ouais mais je pense que je pense que ça
devient juste curieux des choses il ya
des crânes intéressant à voir derrière
pour raconter l'histoire d'un monsieur
en tout je pense que je pense que même
si entrevue ce un journal de merde il
faut savoir une chose c'est que quand
même vous faites du pseudo journalisme
donc fait ces jeunes est vendu il ya
sept ans dans ceux de journalisme non
mais c'est pas pour donc ceux de
journalisme il ya journalisme ce qui
veut dire qu'au moins un minimum on se
rend compte quand on se regarde c'est
juste je sais pas savoir ce qui sera pv
comme cette journaliste pouvait le
savoir je pense et son pv a quand même
marqué qu'à trois personnes qui jettent
dessus je suis tout seul avec ma copine
maintenant si c'est moi après qui passe
pour l'agresseur c'est quand même assez
bizarre
donc le fait que vous ayez écrit ça et
je vous connaissais pas en plus pâles
autant je trouve déranger je vais
demander qu'on mange pas pendant un
quart d'heure en le suivant dans la rue
s'il connaissait ma ganache pour savoir
de quoi il parlait si vous connaissez en
fait voilà et c'est ce qui lui a fait
peur ce jour là si je m'étais écouter
j'aurais joué au football avec lui je
n'ai pas fait ce que je fais pas de la
mecque
ce qu'il faut dire la vérité c'est qu'un
mec est passé en bagnole qui a vu que
j'allais me faire assassiner sur place
qui m'a recueillie dans sa voiture j'ai
mis deux gros coups de pied dans la dans
la bagnole des portières étaient en
creux comme ça le mec s'est arrêté huit
cents mètres plus loin
j'ai dit je suis sorti de la voiture
vous voulez que je vous rembourse pour
la porter un maillot non c'est pas grave
l'assurance paiera si vous aviez mis
dans ma tête j'avais émis dans la
bagnole je serais mort oui et en plus
avec un policier l'a qui voulaient même
pas nous un policier
il a sauté sera bien là le bon bah pour
finaliser sa souvenu donc c'est que
voilà c'est fini maintenant
ouais jusqu'à vendre et l'hôtesse de
l'air c'est elle qui vous avez agressé
aussi bah ouais mais bon comme je dis
toujours c'est sans obligation d'achat
alors qu'est ce qu'on en veut puis ça
change rien faut juste savoir qu'à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui quand ils aèrent
france qui nous demande car qui me
demande de l'argent par rapport à un
manque à gagner vu qu'elle a quand même
pour une gifle après six mois de congé
maladie ait donc j'ai dû à un manque à
gagner j'aurais pu arriver le buzz et
pendant un an et demi de fer france qui
me demande ça yarka médaille la sécurité
sociale qui me demandent aussi d'argent
ouais ça veut dire que j'ai déjà ça m'a
déjà coûté 200 mille balles entre comme
ça trois cent mille balles et là on en
demande encore 300 et il avait giflé en
première pour soi comment pour ce prix
là maintenant justement un an mais je
leur ai dit raillé pour ce prix là pour
ce prix là j'avais des femmes c'est pas
bien et vous aider à mieux là de quoi
vous avez l'air mieux plus calme c'est
parce que vous avez un disque avant tout
parce que vous êtes fait soigner
diego
voilà c'est un brin fogiel s'est passé
pas bon sur cette île ironie fogel c'est
peut-être lui qui vote soit à mon égard
quand même
l'état nous a peut-être un méta maurer
one façon je suis amoureux chamorro ce
que je fais je suis mort d'autres choses
enfin tac mais même pas sa lancée non
c'est pas ça c'est que je pense que je
pense qu'avant avant j'allais sur les
plantes et les gta v kool shen donc il y
avait à côté 10 millions mais plus
aujourd'hui je me retrouve tout seul
donc par c'est à moi de le jeu de
l'agencé ce côté là les lions n'ont pas
plus mal d'ailleurs pas ce qu'on entend
parler plus et puis c'est vrai pas une
brute épaisse qu'un petit shorty bonnes
affaires les dents en or et c'est lille
est bien
il
pour que ce jeu
alors joeystarr c'est à dire un truc
fayel à chauffer les pneus l'aiem
déraillé joey starr
vous êtes un petit peu souvent dans la
quatrième dimension on va vous faire une
interview quatrième dimension
[Applaudissements]
la recherche khalifa qui dit que vous
avez bougé par le jingle milos pas vous
le dire il a raison en cercle alors quel
pays de la quatrième dimension
choisiriez vous pour vivre le pays où on
travaille pas le pays on vieillit pas où
le pays on n'est jamais malades sauver
ou je m'appelle bazooka et on rigole
tout le temps la ville que vous
choisiriez dans la quatrième dimension
la ville où il n'y a que vous celle où
vous n'avez que des amis ou si elle n'y
a que des femmes car c'est toujours ça
en fait il n'y a que mes amis dans la
quatrième dimension tout est possible
vous en profitez pour aller sur mars
pour se taper le crous ou pour faire
avorter la maman d'hitler piétiner la
mère de claire pendant qu'elle est
enceinte
je suis ignobles comme ça je m'appelle
nique ta mère pour ces raisons-là des
appareils comprendre le truc avant
l'oeuf
c'est pas terrible que je ne rentre dans
la quatrième dimension le temps est
différent vous en profitez pour vous
offrir un retour dans votre enfance
une fois par semaine pour faire des
escapades dans le futur ou pour vivre le
temps présent au maximum en l'étirant
voix suis temps présent au maximum en
étirant quatrième dimension il ya un
autre calendrier vous choisissez le mois
où l'argent est gratuit le mois où les
joints tourner pendant 30 jours ou le
mois où on bande quatre semaines
qu'est-ce qui fait déjà tiré ouais il a
doublé et filmé toute la journée jeux
ouais je je suis comme tout le monde va
pas fort non du quartier quoi je suis
quartier alors maintenant on va faire un
anti portrait chinois
tous
ancien notaire si vous étiez un défaut
vous soyez quels défauts je je suis
myope
ouais c'est formidable quand on est
mieux vous êtes dans la même pièce que
que didier schuller et vous le voyez pas
ouais ça peut aider en vous n'êtes pas
si vous étiez un accident de glace j'ai
fait un accident naturel peut-être j'ai
rêvé d'être un raz-de-marée parce que la
mer ont dû fait seule la vallée
tellement de choses quand même quelques
axes revanche si vous étiez une
perversion de voyeur le voyeurisme
j'aimerais bien rentrer voir des gens
comme ça comment il veut dans la tête
ouais dans leur tête mais aussi de chez
eux un sage adore rsa une mouche si vous
étiez une guerre est la norme veut
débarquement en normandie
ça c'était il ya eu des français qui en
débarquant là où l'un des fusilliers
marins qui ont débarqué en normandie
les premiers les premiers sur la plage
de riva-bella et beaucoup sont grands
c'est vrai que c'était très beau si vous
étiez une arme un opinel ou un truc
comme ça pour le figa tél écoutons corse
alors un supplice il ya un très beau
supplice
que j'ai en tête qui est celui de
tantale mais il est dans l'eau et puis
l'eau arrive jusque là il a soif
je propose qu'on replace le par dudu
vendront d'année ou par un petrus un
très bon bordeaux
c'est une cicatrice je vais pas vous la
montrer mais je suis ouvert de la jusque
là oui c'est la mer et j'aime bien je la
touche à la touche si vous y étiez une
[ __ ]
vous seriez qui moi j'aime pas le mot
parce que j'ai jamais dit ça une femme
mais bien dommage
pourtant en soit chacun son truc mais
j'ai jamais dit ça il fane jamais c'est
à chacun son truc c'est on est tous
comme ça tant normal
voilà je pensais je pensais à simone
signoret dans les diaboliques n'en est
pas là pas la personne nationale joue
madame de merteuil dont elles sont
dangereuses d une femme qui fait des
trucs extraordinaires amants diaboliques
mais qui arrive à faire affaire tué son
amant par la maîtresse de cette annonce
est si vous étiez un dictateur quel
dictateur seriez-vous j'aime pas ça je
pensais me sall et charlie chaplin quand
il joue avec audel il s'appelle la
dictature l'est avec un ballon que le
monde c'est pas drôle si vous êtes
j'aurais voulu qu'on pose ces questions
là mais on peut déposer son ancien beau
matelas posés à toi la prochaine si vous
étiez une torture à dire une tête à tête
avec la reine d'angleterre
ah oui c'est les oreilles si vous étiez
une torture moi je m'appellerai
sodomites ou alors si j'étais une
torture je m'appellerai cocaïne par
exemple voilà ça c'est une vraie réponse
et c'est pour ça que des questions au
bois de tout à l'heure là
macha grecque voilà un dictateur ou
autres l'ont fait il a envie de jouer là
vous étiez un terroriste vous seriez qui
comme terroriste un mec qui roule en
ferrari et qui s'arrêtent pas au cas où
si vous étiez une injure vous seriez
quelle injure on va manger la culotte à
ta vieille si vous étiez une cuillère
version joey starr gesta en forme
ouais vous êtes en forme là si vous
étiez à vis à vis à vis je dirai comment
il s'appelle l'autre était même michael
youn ouais parce que quelque part sur un
vice c'est le morning live sur m6 tous
les matins à la mémé c'est même pas pour
lui faire un et en quoi que ce soit si
je suis pas démago moi c'est vraiment
parce que je le crois il a mal quelque
part si vous étiez une arme s'il est
énorme
nique ta mère mais avec pas chez sony
mais si vous étiez une mort un truc bien
horrible la tête dans une baignoire
parce que veut on veut que je dise où je
vais mon mag ou un truc ridicule devrait
être temporaire pour savoir d'accord qui
s'étend la tête et blablabla et on
permet de sourds ça franchement ça c'est
pire que de te brûler les pieds ou parce
que le gaz ou des choses comme ça
d'accord un moment d'inconscience et 1 6
8 points
là c'est vraiment c
sait on peut te l'a serrée et le corps
humain trop bien fait c'est de refaire
le monde est super conscience
ouais mais quand on te noies c'est
claustrophobie même ceux qui savent pas
ce que c'est après las moment des hymnes
à kiel france soir vous étiez de mort
d'amour dans mon livre je cite il marque
est très belle à un moment il raconte la
mort de kafka qu'elle est très belle
parce qu il vraiment de la morphine il
et il est en train de mourir c'est l'
c'est d'abord lui tient tant à temps il
demande de la morphine l'équipe en a pas
ou lits dont il y en a pas il dit cette
phrase extraordinaire dit tuez moi sinon
vous êtes un assassin
joey starr
[Musique]
non
bonsoir elle est là vous connaissez tous
le monde j'aurais ici on est plus ou
moins ouais alors on va écouter votre
single qui est toujours non j'ai pas de
single en ce moment ça
[Musique]
seul parti
monsieur
[Musique]
suit pas
joey starr gazelle
[Applaudissements]
sur la bande son du film astérix et
obélix mission cléopâtre d'alain chabat
alors comment ça se passe à la radio la
radio très skyrock savoir skybox on est
premiers nationale le samedi donc de mon
lapin ouais
heureusement que ça se termine à 22
heures ça ne nous en ait pas trop de
clients samedi mais je dis ça commence à
minuit donc mais vous n'êtes pas là j'ai
mena c'est une chance pour nous
peut-être et à partir du 4 janvier joey
starr à 20h du lundi au vendredi à 20h50
le samedi vous êtes sur canal+ pour une
émission qui s'appelle 60 jours et 60
nuits vous allez être suivie nuitées
jours par une caméra comme ozzy osbourne
l'a été sur mtv aux états unis vous avez
accepté volontiers de faire sa voix du
mal au début mais ouais puis c'est pas
comme ozzy osbourne vu que c'est pas
scénarisée
j'ai pas de nez rouge enfin un quotidien
là c'est mon quotidien quoi on rajoute
pas assez d'accord comme il se doit et
rien inventé enfin j'ai pas mal inventé
avec vous et la caméra vous suivent
nuitées jours ouais me casse les
couilles comme ça et ça va d'ailleurs à
ils sont là ah oui prennent l'habitude
et a même donné des petits noms déjà ça
se passe pas par dans catherine quel
petit nom vous leur avez donné devant de
catherine barma qui vous adore chouchou
et cauna ce souhait connard à la 4e tu
es servi ces jeux qui donnent de
catherine barma joeystarr c'est qui
c'est la coproductrice de l'émission
ok elle vous adore si vous pouvez lui
faire une photographe avant de partir
parce que est très très fan de vous dans
l'émission ça me gêne pas que cette
émission soit produite par endemol qui
produit loft story star academy
on ne peut pas plaire à tout le monde
non pas seulement moi ça me dérange pas
après tout ça c'est de la logistique ça
se passe avec mon manager je vais pas
faire à eux directement donc lanvin
après j'ai un droit de regard que je
pense que à partir de là c'est vous qui
avez ouais c'est vous qui avez comme on
dit le final cut quoi ouais voilà c'est
bon alors moi personnellement au départ
j'étais pas super chaud et puis
finalement ça se passe bien voir là le
bordel chez moi un truc de dingue
j'essaie d'évoluer là dedans à tête vous
qu elle est sauvée canal joey starr
ouais non c'est la merde a marre
enfin des cas on a hâte de voir ouais
merci
j'appartiens
joey starr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui avait mis son fauteuil
[ __ ] belle départ où les merveilles là
il va tomber c'est pas bon du tout ça
fait attention du web a pas de faire mal
non plus quand même ouais
comment ça va laisser ta vie je me suis
fait faire le même coup que toi la coupe
bannière pour faire plaisir à deux bouts
c'est bien dans la semaine dernière il
va jan sur ce plateau t'as vu l'émission
non tu as écouté leurs scellés non
j'aime pas la démagogie donc voilà je
suis pas devant ma tv c'est quoi ton
prénom pour parler d'ailleurs les lits
va te dire un truc je et ce afin de
gérer un fil par les remercie parce que
le crier derrière alors c'est à tous ces
morceaux c'est tout et le morceau que tu
préfères de l'environnement
un bisou et b1 un bisou car si le tu
veux le bisou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez
beaucoup de demandes de 10 ont fait
revivre
je dis un truc jouer elle a fait la même
chose à akhenaton la semaine dernière ça
va te faire coeur le cul déjà beaucoup
de visons 10 mois dont que ouais t'as
pas écouté le cd de iamal au site j'ai
une émission jeudi qui s'appelle jeudi
jour de sodomie à minuit chinois et donc
si donc on passe au pas du rap français
ou promotion de rap français dans tous
ses états et donc ouais j'ai écouté j'ai
écouté le maxi est de 3 titres l'album
on l'a reçue mais c'est toujours pas
écouté un noble art c'est pas mal non
c'est quoi la question
ok ben autre question c'est toujours sur
iam alors les adhérents les a découvert
un petit peu plus mûr père de famille
concernée par le monde qu'ils allaient
laisser à leurs enfants je suis pas
concernée voir à ce moment-là ça tu
étais pas concernés alors j'ai fait
office dame an et de 1,2 fils ait refusé
de grandir at étape a vu la discussion
avec le député de l'ump sur le sol
cannabis la cible et j'ai besoin de ça
alors ils veulent donner des amendes
soit dix mille balles soit 1000 mal
pourquoi moi je te demande ça parce
qu'on a parlé pendant toute l'émission
de la semaine dernière et je te demande
ce que tu penses des amendes pour les
consommateurs de cannabis chez mec tu
consommes pas mais qu'est ce que tu
penses pour les mets qui consomme quoi
votre façon de toute façon je trouve
qu'il ya des mesures toi c'était quoi je
reprends la base la base du projet de
loi c'est leur prendre leur véhicule
porteur bordel les scooters on parle
excuse moi quoi est-ce qu'on lui et puis
de toute façon je pense que ça changera
rien en fait est que et qui n'ont ni
encore moins aux urnes
autant qu on est quoi bon prendre le
point 1 par là quoi tu te rappelles que
je suis vendre un dvd
c'est un truc que j'aime pas faire et
ouais donc faisons le et puis après on
se dit des conneries pour qu'on veut
ouais tu le vends ton dvd un peu
non c'est surtout en fait plutôt que de
le vendre je règle beaucoup de gens le
voient et quoi ouais que si on pouvait
le diffuser sur les places publiques
bush la plus riche ouais ouais c'est
vrai sur faire payer l'entrée bien sûr
tu es prêt pour l'interview suicides
n'ont pas forcément mais ça c'est moi
qui me suicide interview suicide
[Musique]
joey starr bonsoir vous avez en forme
les gens sont crispés ils ont arrêté de
faire l'amour ce conte et je vais me
faire masser au bout de trois questions
si tu veux joey starr bonsoir vous à
l'air en forme
comment ça va vous sentez de prison là
si c'est pour les questions qu'un singe
est chose à [ __ ] ça revenait donc il
est vrai truc c'est bien moi j'aime bien
d'accidents plus tu auras traduit par
toi même et j'aime bien l'accident ça
veut dire tu vas signé dupuy est
consciente sa moitié les stars ça fait
longtemps vous avez pas frappé une
hôtesse de l'air vous prenez le train ou
quoi non ça me manque
comment va votre singe oui c'était pas
le mien c'est vrai que vous l'avez
manger en vrai en fait
en fait chez nous au bénin et là bas on
au môle est la viande de singe avant de
la déguster mais dans un conjoncture
spécial ben voilà
mais c'est bon la viande de singe ans à
la texture du poulet c'est pas mal hein
il n'y a pas des maladies abbas qui
paraissait pas c'est par le sage qui est
arrivé le sida 1 décroché dès qu'on le
fait cuire un jour je suis allée chez
des amis à moi de lui à neige et branché
enfin c'était marrant quand les grands
parents qui étaient arrivés tak tak et
c'était bien avant l'histoire du sang
gerin et genre comme on dit chez nous
ils ont ramené du bon manger tak tak
2000 ont ramené des trucs dans de l'alu
il est arrivé la veille et il faut
chauffer un truc ils l'ouvrent et
c'était un singe et on se servait en
fait la farce à l'intérieur on servait
qu'à la pâte qui était grillé ce qui
était bon en fait on le tapis pour
attendrir la viande alors il se doit ou
lui qu'il fait à targu celui-ci s'est tu
vois comment je crois qu'on va changer
l'interview choisit pas on aime six mois
bon ben on va quand même c'est un max de
terminer voilà je viens par un milliard
sur les cinq à l'interview guimauve
[Musique]
interview qui n'ont joeystarr c'est quoi
votre fleur préférée des singes pour
vous joeystarr c'est quoi la soirée
idéale a2a qu'un songe la plus
romantique que vous ayez fait dans votre
vie contrairement à ce que tout le monde
croit je ne suis au possible donc j'en
fais plein ouais nan mais souvent on
croise avec un petit bouquet de fleurs
bien sûr que je ne connais pas mais qui
connaissait bien sûr je me tiens dans la
bouche en plus c'est quand la dernière
fois qu'une femme vous a blessé jo et
enfin sens figuré bien sûr quand on a
porté plainte
ces sélections
satané de questions dures et ses
interviews guillemot 20 ans mais un
biseau écoute j'ai horreur genre tu
étais pour moi te situes devient tactile
en plus
benzema n'y ait des univers sonores pour
les tourner en bleu sur les joues et j'y
arrive pas y en a pour
non c'est jessy venir à la télé un grave
tu as l'impression de faire un film
1 j'ai compris que après il aurait fallu
que le vendent 1 et j'étais dix fois
plus inquiet par sa queue pas refaire le
film
c'est un truc sans exercice que j'aime
pas du tout c'est pas mal pourtant
commencé comme les autres donc ce tuer
c'est sûr que ça fait le trou c'est
qu'ils les autres c'est gynéco
[Musique]
donc
la ramène moi quand c'est joey starr toi
moi je suis comme tout le monde j'ai
très peur c'est clair il ya un truc un
truc tous les deux non marchand entre
hétéros donc la passe comme ça se passe
bien quoique l etat rondelle quand même
le premier documentaire sur le bo
espèces
c'est à dire les gars des aurès health
bien c'est ce qu'est ce que ça veut dire
bos au scandale stratégie j'arrête ouais
c'est ça c'est ouais sa stratégie par le
scandale c'est en fait de bruit plus on
montre qu'on existe c'est un peu comme
les chiens qu'on puisse en puisant dans
les coins sauf que nous fait pipi sur
les autres si un plein parce qu'ils nous
emmerdent surtout ta [ __ ] et donc qu'il
me faisait peur non j'en dis ce dimanche
donc pourquoi ça va ça faisait peur
tutoyait donnons jamais l'oreille est
dedans tout petit c'est très grand soir
la durée sa vaillance et joey starr
qu'elle adore et chutant et jérôme le
banner bonsoir bonsoir ça va vous
passiez dans le quartier là ouais ça à
temps et du mur c'était bien vous êtes
bien ici alors joe et comment ça va
aller voir jamel debbouze au casino de
paris hier soir ça ça vous a plu
voici tu verras ça ça vous a fait rire
assez way m'a fait participer un peu
allez voir ce que vous êtes monté sur
scène
non non non mon manager ou pas alors
jérôme bernard bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le numéro mondial de kahone le cas one
c'est de la boxe thaï pratiqué par des
gens assez assez corpulent se rend
souvent assez peureux me dit ça arrive
ça lorsqu'on appelle des chiottes tout à
feu alors le box set à rien et provoquer
des clashs le boxster utilise ses pieds
ses points ses genoux c'est oui griffe
souvent le cinéma tuèrent aussi le
ceinture mais justement le cas one donc
ça c'est des arts martiaux pratiqués par
des gens de plus de 90 kg 1
vous y tient un sport violent c'est
animal ça sent le fauve dans l'arène
c'est vrai alors les participants
s'affrontent pendant toute l'année à
travers des épreuves éliminatoires
et puis en décembre il ya la finale des
huit meilleurs au japon là vous défiler
en europe puis en maillot
c'est l'interview suicide
jérôme c'est un sport très populaire est
prise si tu savais qu'on avait presque
personne et même des trucs incroyables 0
c'est un sport qui est très populaire
dans le monde entier qui est de plus en
plus répandu en france même si les
médias en parlent pas beaucoup un peu
votre un peu on passe on passe au
apprenez les grands sports en tennis
ouais hein mais c'est un grand sport oui
les gens qui aiment bien et on vous fait
toutes vos entrées sur le ring sur la
musique de joey starr et vous joey starr
avec dadou vous avez fait la musique un
certain nombre de morceaux du nouveau
film d'alain chabat qui s'appelle voilà
donc avec les robins jean rochefort
gérard depardieu et vous joey starr moi
je suis une apparition métier c'est bien
la musique que vous avez fait si ça
assez d'atouts café ça
[Musique]
pas
/
voilà c'est donc pour le film rôle
d'alain chabat avec les robins on en
parlera plus longuement la la semaine
prochaine avec alain chabat et jean paul
rouve
alors c'est génial victoire c'est un
policier préhistorique complètement en
une scène c'est assez génial et vous
jouez star vous jouez vous faites les
seigneurs de gourdins change pas trop
mais fait c'est pas un rôle de
composition finalement ça s'est bien
passé le tournage one pour moi ça a été
très courtois duroueix je pense être une
dizaine de minutes
ouais j'suis pas chaude à eddy cue bond
que cela fait très vite quoi inviter
bien vous voudrez sûrement vraiment il
est bien le film tu l'as lu non bah
ouais mais de façon je suis venu un peu
le vent donc je vais pas dire qu'il
pouvait non plus la raison que j avais
pas pensé gens qui viennent pas du sable
puis je suis pas chabal et robert moi
c'est un style alors vous dadou vous
étiez tavares dans gomez et tavarès les
fameux ripoux j'ai adoré ça vous le
savez d'ailleurs maintenant ils sont
devenus gomes et du bois pourquoi vous
êtes parti parce que ça partait d'une
une intention assez assez saine et une
intention assez spontané et quand ils
devenus
une exploitation commerciale dans le bon
sens du terme
ça ne m'intéressait plus parce que
j'avais plus le j'avais plus j'avais pu
le spontané qui a vu au départ mais il
est pas mal d'albums d'amasser du
boisnant n'est pas moi il n'y a pas de
problème sur soi mais moi je me sentais
vraiment pas de quoi vous sentez pas de
mentir en rouge ouais alors dadou après
de nombreux featurings vous avez fait un
premier album en avril 2003 qui
s'appelle france history x c'est sur
l'intégration
aujourd'hui et vous dit que finalement
l'intégration aujourd'hui c'est des
petites histoires
c'est exactement et c'est dans le texte
je décris un peu une famille française
moyenne avec un fils qui écoutent du rap
une fille qui sort avec ali qui est qui
fait le ramadan qui fait le ramadan est
pour moi l'intégration elle passe par
ces petites choses là le poste par deux
histoires d'amour des fois elle passe
pas plein de petites choses qui en font
des grandes
c'est vrai qu'en fait vous dit que
maintenant les jeunes ils savent ce que
c'est le ramadhan match albigeois dedans
messieurs et finalement il a pu la
télévision qui ne qui ne sait pas
comment ça se passe quoi je pense moi je
pense vraiment que la vie et le continue
à se faire dans la rue avec des gens
et au jour le jour un écueil
qu'aujourd'hui synthétiser l'information
à des faits divers et en faire une
une peinture sociale c'est un peu
s'éloigner de la réalité
alors votre prochain album doit sortir
cette année oui je prends sur vous
viendrez nous en parler j'espère bien
mais j'espère bien on peut lui donner
une carte
voilà très bien merci bien comme vous
revenez quand vous voulez vous êtes les
biens
alors vous dit en fait mon rêve c'est le
jazz mon inspiration au niveau du flou
c'est miles davis vous pensé aller plus
vers le jazz dans l'avenir - vers le rap
disons que je pense à faire beaucoup
plus de musique en général et de
vraiment démontré que le rap ça a été
comment dire la musique de mon époque
ouais et que et que je respecte vraiment
est ce qui s'est passé avant parce qu'il
a une histoire avant le rap on peut
arriver les prétendre révolutionner
quelque chose donc c'est vraiment faire
le relais entre ce qui s'est passé et ce
qui se passera quoi alors john et
comment ça va vous savez que les gens
vous aiment de plus en plus de jouer
vous êtes d'ordre de plus cette année
vous êtes bientôt dans le top 50 des
français préféré des français vous le
savez ça je suis pas je capital
sympathie moins cette fois montreuil non
mais vous êtes énorme capital de
sympathie et demi qu'on fasse une
interview qui vous montre sur votre
meilleur jour je suis pour je me suis
réveillée alors si tu t'es réveillé pour
satan cananzi la dernière fleur bleue
[Musique]
joey starr à l'interview fleur bleue est
ce que vous croyez au coup de foudre de
jouer ouais ouais
est ce que vous étiez timide la première
fois on met toujours entre eux sont elle
s'appelait comment la première vous en
souvenez pas tout de suite
est ce que vous l'avez est ce que vous
les aimez écrire un poème au moins
j'aurai n'ont même pas non pour
regretter est ce que vous demandez
conseil à votre meilleure amie en cas de
peine de coeur non c'est pas comme ça
que c'est comme ça que ça se passe
normalement oui nandrin des fables bien
sûr non enfin j'en parlerai au conseil
ne vous demandez pas conseil ballon est
ce que vous aimez effeuiller les
marguerites je t'aime un peu beaucoup
passionnément à la folie pas du tout sa
marque et fait marquer vélo là
adieu et on fait quoi pour la
saint-valentin jeu
j'envoie des fleurs à botmeur à votre
mère c'est tout bon a quelques uns des
autres sites web à ma mère
principalement d'accord vous offrez des
roses rouges n'ont pas votre mère ouais
si je me rende ma mère donc ouais un
niveau cinq ans parle un joueur ça vous
dirait jo et des violons sur votre
prochain disque c'est quoi la question
c'est vrai que tu penses à faire une
reprise et petit bonhomme en mousse ou
hélas
besoin de bouddhisme voici joey starr
salut
est ce que tu as déjà été tentée dans le
bouddhisme alors je bois du roman jamais
été tenté par la méditation
transcendantale non merci
non ya pas une religion qui t'attend tu
es un moment jamais non un grand conflit
avec ma mère ça justement votre mère
elle est croyante
ouais les catholiques bas comme tout les
gens qui ont été changés de la colonie
13 bat non non non merci
tat j'ai pas besoin garde-fous quoi un
mois j'ai foi ou gens qui m'entourent et
en moi
le bouddhisme ça peut faire du bien
arriver à un homme sûrement arriver à se
détacher les désirs non j'ai pas vous
mais ça va ouais gentiment gentiment le
couple eu un congrès alors tu es
toujours le patron du boss le collectif
boss et le boss du boss à la fin bon
score en plus un premier jour ça mange
bien bref savoir alors le nouvel opus du
collectif bosse donc un s'appelle opus 3
parce que c'est le troisième mois
m
sur l' on a créé
fumer
organisée
un bon match
[Applaudissements]
utilisons nous soulager les
allers-retours à paris tous je suis prêt
par la ba ouais mais tu m appelles dadou
à la réalisation c'est pour ça que je
vais là-bas je vais chez lui dans son
fief
ouais et ça avance je pense que on se
retire à sable pour décembre 2005 2005
elle s'en est super dernier moment comme
d'habitude non ouais dans l'urgence
trop dur c'est à dire qu'on démarre
avant mais on fait toujours des joueurs
ouais voilà dans l'urgence actuelle en
général alors la passer en revue le rap
français savent pas où ça en est là la
rumeur c'est bon la rue main c'est vrais
gens booba ne lui a pas là je peux faire
un bon c'est pourquoi il faut qu'on soit
jeune ou va lui mettre un paon c'est un
mec bien
un père et son fils non justement
je suis arrivé en retard la première
m'ont dit les dates fidèles délai d un
voyage est ce un assassin non pourquoi
la mère assise de la mer arrête je t'ai
trouvé harcèlement je trouve que tu vas
bien
ouais ministère amer qui se reforment
d'ailleurs tu es au courant
athènes a rien à [ __ ] ans qui centre
c'est en train de refaire bassiste me
qui se monte à cornet des trains
je viens tu fait dans la nuance
quand il sait qu en direct
kool shen wei cipla trois jours tu
disais musicalement ça me plaît pas du
tout mais je vais me dire ouais super à
dakar a ici non musicalement j'ai un
problème avec moi c'est un peu de la
musique d'ascenseur mais sinon c'est un
des mecs qui est le mieux pour moi c'est
vrai qu'il écrit bien et tu trouves que
ses mélodies sont un peu légères et
faciles non c'est pas les mélodies
l'épreuve derrière quand je trouve
ouais j'ai trop léger ou quoi ouais ça
c'est sûr c'est pas ça
tu as vu la violence du truc quand ça
commence là
ça me rappelle un peu l'album de
christine deviers joncour beaucoup de
couples c'est le genre de groupe et
ouais bon continuer même si jean gabin
alors voila tu es sympa comme tout il
peut être sympa sur le plateau de télé
sinon chez nous là à la voir c'est une
aubaine pour nice marque de vélos des
rigolos tête lundi quand il veut je
l'attends sur scène pourquoi parce que
inexistant assez inexistant bah je sais
pas moi j'ai plein de gens qu'ils ont
envie de faire juste son morceau je
t'emmerde
ouais c'était n'importe quoi un mention
il a du mal moi ou elle minimum juste
cinq heures jeudi raconte quant à 10 est
un rappeur avec un string sur la tête
c'est vrai que c'est pas très sympa
rapidement comme commises et booba quoi
son nom il se nourrit sur la mort même
si jean gabin bien maintenant un petit
gérard philipe c'est pas bon pied le
cinéma aussi ah bon tu va tourner en
février 2005
ouais je peux en parler d'un truc tu que
je fasse le pitch savoir ses quatre
filles sublimes
c'est ça qui me sens fort qui sont
toujours en bikini comme paris en ligne
braquage et humilient les hommes elles
s'envolent pour la réunion et la tombe
sur un réunionnais elle tombe sur un mec
s'appelle mustapha qui est jouée par toi
et tu tiens en otage marjolaine et elles
veulent libérer marjolaine qui s'appelle
claudette la tour voilà cheval pitch
c'est remettre bien c'est la même pudeur
initial ayant une histoire d'amour je
pense le syndrome de stockholm je ne dis
rien je pas non j'ai pas lu moi j'ai
rien vu encore ouais donc je t'apprends
je sais que ça doit se faire sous peu
c'est en février
alors avant la réunion avant le paradis
avant le rêve on va faire une interview
cauchemar
[Musique]
joey starr
vous vivez ou dans vos cauchemars je
fais pas de cauchemar ça oui t'as pas un
autre truc lâm interview chez moi mais
non mais elle est bien c'est une terre d
eau à dire je fais des cauchemars et est
déjà là ce soir pourquoi c'est un
cauchemar je fais un cauchemar dont
votre copine elle vous trompe avec qui
dans vos cauchemars
j'apprécie beaucoup ranca me trompe-je
tous nantais cauchemar est il va la
tabasser crois que c'est vrai un peu con
droit
c'est quoi votre métier de jouer dans
vos cauchemars des mouches j'écoutais
quoi comme musique dans vos cauchemars
stomy bugzy que ça bien c'est qui qui
est en tête du top 50 dans vos
cauchemars répondent ministère amer vous
avez peur de quoi dans vos cauchemars
iam vous mourrez commandants locaux
chemin en écoutant du stomy bugzy nous
montrer à quel âge dans vos cauchemars à
l'âge des cerises et vous découvrez quoi
sur vous dans vos cauchemars que je
ressemble à pacy vous fait attaquer par
quel genre d'animal dans vos cauchemars
un sarcellois elle ressemble à quoi
l'humanité dans vos cauchemars
c'est parce que ça me ferait de pire
cauchemar ouais vous aider sur quel
plateau télé dans vos cauchemars
tu as je fais drucker thaler a pas mal
voilà c'était pas mal il est 11 - de ces
tirs n'ont rien à [ __ ] de ce que je
raconte peut-être non mais un citoyen
actif tu connais pas tiens le voilà
regarde le site
[Applaudissements]
monsieur
les actifs
ouais bon
commence pour affronter sénat
djamel vaut mieux pas essayer un qui moi
il m'a planté 3 l'apport du jour besson
l'audio il m'a dit alors c'était bien le
dîner jamel qui n'est pas venue mais dit
mais moi il n'est pas venu au mieux les
dynamiter la promotion d'angela le
collectif la rhumerie juliette bientôt
et du taf
comment ça va un citoyen actif ça va ça
va aller voter alors faut aller voter
est par contre opposé son répondeur
téléphonique lui il me demande de le
rappeler il en thaïlande
tu permets un peu ta casquette parce que
je te vois pas là ça va lâcher voilà je
suis pas allé chez le coiffeur
assez pour sa suce d'insultant avec le
collectif la griffe et getti ball alors
jusqu'à présent avait fait un bain
jusqu'à la fin du mois de décembre la
faune allemand il a après en fait ça
recommence en septembre prochain jusqu'à
décembre jusqu'à décembre
c'est un endroit que ça serait que de
septembre me demande pas comment ça
fonctionne voir franchis pas je peux au
fait de tout ça c'est normal on aura je
sais que ça fonctionne comme ça
d'ailleurs nous ont lâchés au dernier
moment se sont un peu pour ça que le
truc c'est monter enfin l'appel on a eu
deux semaines un peut pas appeler tous
les médias et pour y aller quoi ce qui
ce qui fait un peu qu'on a une
légitimité pour aller dire aux gens un
peu aussi à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
s'il vous plaît allez vous inscrire et
puis réagissez fédéraux nous et ainsi de
suite
c'est que justement fait déjà la base un
travail de fois aidé à sausheim des as
aux auscitains
mais il faut absolument tout le monde
prenne conscience qu'il fallait chercher
sa carte d'électeur banlieue pas blanc
banlieue arrêter de créer des clans et
nous nous expliquer que ces gens là se
comporte mal ces gens là c'est nous ces
gens là c'est vous c'est toute la france
c'est se tirer une balle dans le pied
que que des toffees et que de sectoriser
comme ça la france est pas possible de
commissions la vérité la réconciliation
non et ça on l'attend en afrique du sud
en afrique du sud pérou en français
jean kiel 23 fermes ayant voté une loi
voilà pour qu on positive l'action
coloniale mais celles ci on va pas au
fond de ce qui s'est passé et de refaire
mon de 2,2 de revenir à la mémoire de ce
qui s'est passé que les gens parlent et
c'est ce qu'ils soient déjà entendu et
qu'on enregistre les toutes les
histoires à ce moment-là ça changerait
déjà dans la situation dans les
mentalités gestion si on va pas dans les
dents les générations d'avant les
générations qui viennent à présent
toujours mal mais c'est un cancer de
façon la france un peu enfin moi j'ai
jadis avait enfin je l'ait remarqué
encore un peu plus dernièrement quoi la
france a un peu un peu peur de regarder
son passé dans les yeux quand
l'appartement
on a colonisé des gens étant donné où on
a toutes les valeurs de démocratie qui
sont les a oubliés quoi y'a un moment
donné je pense que je suis sait tous ces
gens qui aujourd'hui sont un peu
désoeuvrés façon je pense que si on leur
explique qu'en fait c'est la france qui
nous a fait nous sommes français qu'il
ya une vraie histoire autour de ça déjà
je pense que ça va réveiller une
confiance une conscience civique et
ainsi de suite quoi donc c'est un
mouvement pour la vraie liberté la vraie
égalité et la vraie fraternité c'est ça
ça c'est sympa comme monsieur morin
c'est bien comme on n'a pas envie de
penser que c'est utopique vraiment à y
croire parce que moi je crois en mon
pays je pas possible ça possible qu'on
nous explique matin midi et soir qu'on
n'est pas les bienvenus c'est pas
possible de gens et de jeunes quoi
oublier qu'on n'a pas eu de chance quand
d'être en france même s'il ya plein de
choses qui ne pourront bien sûr je pense
que pour parler franchement d'envoyer
les gens s'inscrire et voter
prochainement
c'est sûr qu'en ce moment
si les plus jeunes voyais pratique et ça
comment les automatismes je pense qu'à
long terme il se passera quelque chose
quoi je crois tu veux la faut voir sur
le long terme maintenant c'est sûr et
puis ça peut susciter des vocations
aussi sait très bien que ces prises de
conscience citoyenne à la tout à fait la
passe géniale moyenne placé pour pouvoir
dire ce qui manque en banlieue que ce
soit d'un point de vue social pratiques
ou autre c'est quand les premiers
protagonistes vers les gens qui vive
voix
il ya des gens qui vont pas voter parce
que d'après ils n'ont pas le poids mais
le point une voix elle soir face à une
voie là mais tout le monde ne le sait
pas ça secret mais on voit même qui n'ai
jamais voté donc qui n'est jamais de
caractère le vin je vais chercher ma
carte à tous rendez vous en faites en
face de la mairie de clichy sous bois
ben alaya une journée c'est le 20
décembre à 14 heures voilà pour en garde
organisé une marche
enfin c'est le truc symbolique bien mais
ça va ouais tu sais 20 décembre à la
mairie pour s'inscrire mais voilà c'est
ça prenait conscience une voix égale une
voix
ouais surtout ne vous garez pas aller
chez ce jour 1 jamel anti porte chinois
toi car jamais un jour on casse toi
alors qu'abel inteprète aux lentilles
portrait chinois
et si bien mater jamal dati jamal ça
soit une heure y'a pas de couilles y
reviendra plus à une heure je suis
désolé je voulais pas le faire au départ
[Musique]
ma part je le fais dissidente et
portrait chinois
d'accord on montre joey starr mais là
quand même pour le coût moyen par peter
ce qu'ils faisaient et assez il disait
des blagues racistes
ça fait trois jours qu'il cherche
juliette elle m'a dit [ __ ] c'est
dégueulasse
j'avais le tpr est heureusement que fais
tu ici mais djamel un combo est venu
avec une armée de [ __ ] il ne
m'occupe
depuis que lorsqu'il fait il fait début
des petites menottes individu m'a craché
un peu la gueule c'est pas grave c'est
juste muriel que je voulais pas visé
j'en ai pris un peu monsieur c'est la
compassion mais l'opposition est
variable et on peut tout faire
maintenant tout bouge plus et n'ont rien
pour bracelets we put maintenant mais
est ce que tu sais que ta chaussure
droite c'est fait exprès août a obligé
les tickets des tickets ça s'appelle le
style annonce à celle du vol jamais tu
sais que les parents muriel il vend des
chaussures langues
elle est au courant
on est prêt ouais si c'était un gros mot
maintenant je veux juste vérifier un
truc
quand un pape le pinard à ces mecs de
banlieue c'était sa mort et chercheurs
voilà
suite
mais relève ses marges et lesbiens
j'étais trop petit déj c'est très bien
vas-y tu t'étais un gros mot sa mère
lipopette c'était une guerre une guerre
si j'étais une guerre voilà là et je
serai là que la guerre contre les
pointes sèches et des cheveux cassants
c'était un accident
la coupe du monde derrière la dernière
coupe du monde et de l'année un peu dur
c'était un dictateur
si j'étais un dictateur de charlie
chaplin
j'étais un bruit j'étais un gorille le
bruit qui court que je suis régulier de
bill au chat
je sais pas après l'émission de m6 d'été
assassa inédit nidal sans exception j'ai
eu l'idée une trahison
mon bras droit ce salon avec toute ma
confiance à c'était un meuble un canapé
convertible pour le convertir à l'islam
qu'ils étaient un supplice voté chirac
en 2002 ça c'est un supplice c'était un
légume chirac
[Rires]
si tu étais un peu peur j'étais un
terroriste carlos papayou papayou l'aîné
c'était un saint saint maclou pour les
moquettes
une amicale pour l'heure rien s'il était
un supplice je recommence
j'étais un supplice reste gros coup
merci ça inquiète de la mer des eaux
c'est incroyable dit il j'ai pas envie
de te taper devant tout le monde tu fais
des c'est quoi que tu rigoles comme un
conte de ses blagues c'est pour ça qu'il
va aussi après des regards il
surenchérit et en plus c'est du vol pur
et ils seront tous ses biens par le
requin s'approchent pas du feu non mais
sans blague pas qu'est ce que c'est ça
je peux je peux pas rester comme ça
c'est pas possible
quelqu'un qui est calme trop dans ton
sur ton plateau plus ça y est j'y ai
attrapé la crève mais un petit manteau
pour jamel petite culotte pour joey
starr
petit et chats vas-y vas-y vas-y pardon
si tu étais un animal mon frère mon beau
c'était un importateur de monde a peur
on arrive tu sais pourquoi parce que j'y
viens tu avais pas beaucoup dormi si tu
étais un impôt mon père mais si c'était
une ordure à le père noël ouais tu m'as
oublier - l'année dernière rien ramené
j'ai commandé un astra 2c pc 4
voilà
c'est le charme de cette émission
j'aurais vu jouer star ac ay côte à côte
avec maurice me mettais relève aussi
pour me c'est pour moi pouvait faire
comme chaillot mortalité deux immortels
willow mieux comment ça va durer ça va
merci tu connais maurice donnant j'ai
découvert la terreur sur les concours
grand résistant il s'est battu contre
les nazis pendant la guerre actuelle
oui et lui il y aura une autre forme de
résistance composé du rap je suis dur à
point ab c'est bien ça vous aimez bien
le terme rappeuse pour les faits j'ai
osé
j'ai pas osé le demander non c'est
rapière qu'il faudrait dix écouter ce
qu'on va faire on va on va écouter les
chansons qui fait et si vous voulez
danser
didier
non
[Musique]
ce mois
le temps fera
[Musique]
sa femme et m
comment
[Musique]
mon beau ça
m
[Musique]
le gilet pare balles abbas de propre
camp pas mais pour le hip hop je
développe la seine saint denis
c'est de la bombe bébé et si tu connais
peu particulier
on
[Musique]
voilà joey starr
[Applaudissements]
alors
j'avoue blais maurice côté ça me
surprend un peu mais j'ai parce que j'ai
pas très bien compris les paroles à et
c'est pour ça explique c'est dans ma
benz benz vans et dans une mercedes
il ya fait journée l'oise l'a1 when the
watch il va nous prendre pour des
beatniks quand même c'est dans le dico
c'est quoi le féminin de beatniks
d'ailleurs pique nique ta mère bien
alors
donc jo et bonsoir vous êtes ici pour un
livre qui s'appelle mauvaise réputation
votre autobiographie écrite en
collaboration avec philippe manoeuvre
rédacteur en chef de rock & folk et
publié par laurent chollet chez
flammarion voilà vous avez pris un
rockeur pour écrire une histoire de
rappeur est ce que c'est pas un peu
bizarre ça non je préfère moi je crois
que je suis pas de rock mais je suis un
peu rock'n'roll quoi rives du rhin on
assume on a su se trouver là dessus bord
là au début l'idée de raconter votre vie
ça vous saouler quand même non bah ouais
ouais tu dois savoir en plus à ce que en
général c'est un exercice que je
pratique pas trop quoi ouais
au départ j'étais un peu réticent on a
on n'a pas souvent l'occasion d'être
protagoniste et spectateurs à la fois là
j'ai pu être un peu spectateur du truc
quoi j'ai pu avoir le recul mais ça
c'est ce qui m'a plu un peu aussi quoi
alors on commence au début tu dis nous
sommes une vraie famille
il ya ton père ta mère et toi tes
parents se sont rencontrés aux antilles
ton père entraînait ta mère en france
la france et l eldorado pour les
antilles loin c'était la génération qui
pensaient que ronald en france bon bah
voilà ils ont rien enfin déjà mon avis
ils s'attendaient à voir un statut un
statut qui n'ont pas eu je crois et puis
puis voilà quoi il j allais pour aller
travailler ainsi sud quoi main à ton
père très séducteur à mon père
vous perdez un charbon avec les yeux
gris enfin genre espèce de bellâtre
voilà quoi dit se plaisait beaucoup à
lui-même mais surtout aux femmes quand
il la trompe
ouais en fait ils s'amusent mais la
pauvre un étudie la dernière image que
j'ai de mes parents ensemble c'est eux
en train de se taper dessus
ouais l'époque taqwa 3 4 ans wayne dont
séoul a quoi sa marque
ouais mais bon
avec le temps j'ai réussi un peu à
évacuer tout ce à quoi je le sais ça
reste forcément quoi c'est comment sac à
dos à l'histoire un clash pas quoi mais
moi je crois que de tout ça j'ai réussi
à me faire des choses au final c'est son
fils que j'ai envie de dire dans ce
niveau là quoi c'est malgré le cursus un
moment donné bon ben j'ai réussi à me
réalisés c'est ce qui est le mot passion
et ainsi de suite
alors tes parents divorcent et tempère
magouille pour avoir ta garde tu envoies
une fois c'est le jour de tes seins
quand elle est venue apporter des
cadeaux mais tempère les jettent à la
poubelle
ouais non il ne visait en fait devrait
dire fin il le faisait à chaque fois de
manière continue tacle je crois que
c'est bien après j'ai su qu'elle venait
tous les ans fait très et qui est yes
prenez un mur à chaque fois quoi elle
elle dit c'est mon fils j'ai droit de le
voir bah ouais ce qui est ce que pour
être légitime en plus sains et lui dis
dégage pas rien à [ __ ] là enfin
d'après lui c'était une manière
d'interférer par rapport à une éducation
qu'il avait l'impression de me donner
quoi et puis en plus moi les gamins
qu'on pose des questions pourquoi
pourquoi les autres on nettoie pas
[Musique]
tu arrive enfin tu vis dans une cité
dont tu te rends chez les autres tu vois
d un cadre familial comme ça que tu as
pas chez toi donc à paris par une
question qui se pose et puis j'ai des
questions qu'ils posent à ces jeunes
quoi donc en ont donné comme en face on
puisse y a pas de dialogue donc tu
trouves un peu des réponses tout seul
jamais évident quoi il a dit qu'elle
était morte à un moment un moment donné
ouais ouais mais je pense qu'à mon avis
la dulfer gens fous moi la paix il
m'aurait dit fou moi la paix où elle est
morte ce rythme là même pour lui quoi
mais comment il peut être si dur votre
père est jetable pré comme j'étais pas
l'enfant du placard non plus
mais bah je sais pas non mais je pense
que ça a des circonstances atténuantes
que je lui trouve c'est que il vient
d'un monde rural où il a dû se battre
lui pour aller à l'école alors que
voulait le faire travailler direct et
faille qui ramène de là dessus et puis
qu' il n'était pas très tendre avec lui
non plus quoi moi j'ai vu ma grand-mère
à côté paternel une fois c est ma pas
l'épée comme un bastion quoi enfin nt
sur son perron et puis tout le monde
s'affaire autour aqua décalant regarder
un tout de suite c'était donc je peux
imaginer un peu le contexte aussi dans
lequel lui a dû grandir d'après et là il
circo un peu démuni face à man quoi
voilà vingt puis bon le lycée il a passé
son enfance aux antilles on se retrouve
en france
moi j'ai je vais à l'école enfin je
rencontre des gens mais les moeurs sont
pas les mêmes quoi donc et lui il le
sent pas ce truc à quoi il est très dur
par exemple il vous achète rien du tout
donc vous êtes obligé de jours et dès
l'âge de 1 voie ou enfin ne peut le
petit fed a l'impression de faire alors
que bon on n'en est plus là quoi je veux
dire comme tout le monde le sait on a
dans une certaine société de
consommation à partir on est à un poste
téléviseur chez toi et que je parte à
13,13 10 13 ans tata certaine envie par
rapport à tout ça et que bon ben voilà
il est très dur il ya l'histoire du
lapin jouerie blesse en lapin avec sa
voiture qui ramène de l'apab laissé à la
maison ou du riz commence à s'intéresser
aux lapins d'arrivée une peur à la basse
jamais vue d'animaux chez moi enfin même
approché avec leur des chiens dans la
rue enfin j'étais très donc je me suis
attaché au truc puisqu'il a soigné on
l'a gardé pendant je pars une semaine ou
deux mois je dois avoir une dizaine
d'années quoi donc abandonné c'est le
lapin machin enfin au départ chose à
chuchoter puis après c'était mon lapin
lapin bien dimanche ça ramène le lapin à
moi je l'amène tac de coups de touches
derrière le crâne et os pour y filmer
dans la casserole
et puis tu es obligé de manger quoi
voilà quoi donc lui mais comme j'étais
alors quoi il a grandi dans un contexte
où il y avait des animaux machin que
j'étais coutumes et du fais quoi moi
c'était enfin 93 je veux dire pour toi
c'est un animal domestique pour lui
c'était de la bouffe
ouais ouais voilà ouais en fait je me
suis pas rendu compte qu'ils étaient en
train d'agresser quoi c'est marrant non
mais moi j'en rigole aujourd'hui en soit
les vingt sept devaient être pas vrai en
fait non mais le truc c'est que moi me
suis rendu compte du côté burlesque de
la situation là on la raconte en quoi
mes missions s'il est resté dans un coin
me disent on est curieux quand même
assez curieux at a été élevé sur le
thème n'est pas une gonzesse quoi ouais
entre autres ouais comme à l'armée un
peu aussi c'est un rappel l'armée après
pas de faiblesses pas tu vois c'est à
dire que dans un contexte on ne
communique pas trop niveau affectif
c'est zéro le seul endroit où tu es
peinard finalement c'est l'école quoi
parce que la tombe est en fait c'est une
fois que je passe au seuil de la porte
parce que à un moment donné tu
développes une faculté à évacuer
fort-mardyck sortait de chez moi j'ai
évacué quoi c'est bien
bon après l'école c'est assez
particulier parce que je devais avoir
une blouse
enfin quand j'en parle à mon père
miséreux des meurtres
je vais m'acheter la règle des stylos et
les machins lait caillé était bon le
reste c'est bon quoi aff donc moi
j'avais pour feinter je vais avec une
veste de pyjama en fait je me mettais
une jambe dans le dos tout le temps sans
m'en rendre compte quoi donc s'était
jamais évident quoi
un jour tu te fais choper par les flics
parce que je suis parce que tu as quitte
à piquer ton père vient au commissariat
mais une rouste essais les flics qui
sont obligés de calme et tempèrent ils
ont arrêté bien sûr arrêter de le battre
ouais enfin grosso modo s'était fait ça
chez vous mais pas ici quoi tac
en fait on était une bande de gamins
j'avais
ces conneries là envers la lecture
tournez manège
c'est même pas un larcin et on était
un petit groupe de niaré moment de
sortir du magasin méga séduit semir onyx
il a attrapé deux raclées pied et
l'autre avec une main rats cafards
il y avait moi dans le look à la maison
c'était la ceinture d'abord le bout en
cuir et ensuite le la boucle ouais mais
ouais 13 antilles s à 1 cc culturel ça
va sentir chez nous vous êtes partisan
de cette éducation à la dure pour les
enfants vont pas d'exagération
quand même sur les testicules non pas
d'exagération patchou ce cruel mais il
est certain que petit châtiments
physiques mais mais c'est vrai la paire
de gifles c'est pas mauvais du tout non
c'est vrai écouter ça simplement sur
l'enfant celui des sentiments qui a une
autorité
bah oui là c'était le cas avec diana
c'est tout vous voyez le résultat
voilà alors joey l'adolescence une vie
un peu de merde a fini fait de la colle
à fumer des pétards à piquer des colères
tout va vite une partie une demi heure
pour manger en plus tous les modèles et
la région c'est la révélation la claque
du hip hop des américains qui break au
trocadéro je crois que wes et si tu nous
nos sorties sur paris c'était pas grand
chose à l'époque dans sa cour pour une
fois on a vu quelque chose par les jeux
qu'on défi et voilà donc en fait foi que
c'est pas nous qui avons c'est le truc
qui nous est tombé dessus en puisque à
partir du jour là ça s'est plus jamais
arrêter voix c'est l'acte a rencontré
bruno lopes futur kool shen
en fait il habitait de l'autre côté du
boulevard et
voilà un beau jour par le biais de sa
juste au monde va lui il avait un poste
pas nous voilà c'est tout simplement que
c'était juste cinq ans voilà après tu
raconte la naissance d'ntm le soir du
premier concert tu dis tout vient
naturellement
tu trouve tout de suite tu es truc les
jeux de scène l'écrit bah ça faisait 70
ans que j'étais sous acide donc oui très
on se pose pas trop de questions coin ça
c'est comme comme quand on va où la
scène quoi tu dis diva de la scène
j'aperçois l'infini ouais je l'avais vu
une fois puis après je les ai revus quoi
après et après tu cours après quoi c'est
à dire mais si tu veux surtout que c'est
un contexte assez particulier parce
qu'on fait
j'étais avec kool shen et djs à l'époque
est bon nous on écrivait des textes
enfin c'était vraiment la petite réunion
chez chez ace
on était dans notre microcosme pour ces
gens m'en sortir on faisait des tags par
accident enfin on est tombé sur une
personne qui commence à me dire que rap
et enfin écrit assez réservé à une élite
nous à ce moment qu'on le prenne déjà
pour un abruti donc forcément on s'est
dit pas on va essayer puis si on essaye
prendre une chaise quoi parce que tu
vois leurs besoins puis de là on écrit
des trucs mais qui en fait pour un trek
au graffiti quoi voilà qui raconte ce
qu'on fait en fin de phase on a commencé
comme ça et je crois que je sais pas
faire autre chose on fait quoi
ce n'est pas une mauvaise chose qu'on
puisse qu'en fait on l'a toujours fait
par par esprit de challenge et surtout
pour faire plaisir voix alors vous qui
écrivez un livre tiré des jardins où
vous dites que l'affaissement culturelle
commence avec le rap et le tag voilà
vous avez en face de vous un un rappeur
tiger woods et qui me saute dessus
n'allait pas merci non non mais c'est
vrai que bon on aime bien l'entendre on
est bien mais c'est pas du tout à mes
yeux
la culture moderne d'aujourd'hui mais
c'est tout à fait intéressant séparation
celle du problème et ce que je fais
j'aime pas ce qu'il fait bon passer la
main quand même je fais pas on va pas
faire une guerre non c'est aux ballades
mais c'est vrai je ne vois pas d'avenir
à sa tentative disons pour être gentil
bas pourtant cela fait plus de vingt ans
que ça dure comme
je crois qu'ils donnent rendez vous dans
vingt ans si oui encore pas tous il y en
a plein d'autres derrière moi donc à mon
avis c'est vous qui allez avoir un
problème et puis en plus le truc je
crois que je trouve on vous rendez pas
trop content c'est qu'en fait c'est très
adapté à des gens comme vous qui à la
base j'ai pas prononcé il suffit d'un
enfin il ya besoin de rien quand même
pas de musique de même pas de musique
pour rappel n'y a pas forcément non plus
besoin de musique pour taguer faut juste
être un peu klepto enfin je veux dire
c'est très adapté quoi à des gens qui à
un moment donné ont envie de s'exprimer
ou envie de bouger ou envie de voyager
sans se déplacer ainsi de suite c'est
très adapté c'est très contemporain de
toute façon qu'un galles doit d'aimer sa
part donné les gens que nous nous sommes
quand même tous un peu pareil mais
l'exercice avec des goûts différents
non mais moi je parle bien il ya un
statut social c'est à dire que moi - ont
donné mon seul seul petit plaisir qu'on
chantait de la cité c'était d'aller sur
paris
aux pratiques une école du mépris nous
méprisait donc on rester chez nous et
par le biais de ça on arrive à voyager
en reste entre nous à faire notre truc
pourtant je suis pas je suis pas
quelqu'un de communautariste ou autre
mais ça nous a fait voyager puis
promener aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
pourrait fermer
ben ouais c'est pas à moi que vous le
dire ça parce que c'est pas nous qui
étions demi de prison quoi on subissait
le mépris ce qu'imaginait m'intéresse
beaucoup
qu'avec mon voisin si ceux ci c'est son
vocabulaire il avril un vocabulaire à
deux niveaux et on comprend qu'ils
fassent des textes parce que d'abord le
mot qu'ils emploient le plus souvent qui
violent ces trucs way trip lui sert à
tout voilà et j'en ai d'autres celui de
messi c'est une chose au fond truc
tellement chose qui dise
et puis à côté de ça des yeux du monde
sont passe avant mais qui sort déjà de
d'un niveau d'un niveau de langage c'est
au contexte évacuer microcosme à sillery
donc maurice il serait temps de se
rendre compte que leur a fait aussi
évoluer la langue française et les
laisser les slameurs sont des gens qui
maîtrisent aussi la langue si vous aviez
entendu l'autre jour quand corps malade
vous auriez été épaté par sa dextérité
dans l'écriture
et voilà quoi il y avait un garçon avec
qui j'avais dialoguer c'était un apple
dany brillant dans chaque lycée dès
qu'ils m'appellent public admis kafka
une célébrité
certaines un jeune noir qui est très
bien pour la soutenir mais ça ça venait
du sol ar oui c'est ça il aime pas il
est il écrit bien comme s'est pas
émoussée solaire donc si m6 cela une
quoi arriver règle bien pas l'intérêt si
tu les gens arrivent à s'immiscer dans
mon après les acrobates linguistique ou
autres puisque sans que les acrobates
linguistique ça plaira maurice druon
salariés a omis dadjo et attendait bon
alors après on continue le livre donc jo
et raconte son coup de foudre avec
béatrice dalle vous dit béatrice la
ferrari des gonzesses et quand vous la
rencontrez vous dites je nage dans le
bonheur
non ça se passe un crs bien moi j'ai une
manière un peu plus organique de parler
parce que manoeuvre après ça c'est ça
c'est du manoeuvre dans le bonheur mais
les cigarettes piéger c'est toi ou cette
manoeuvre
ces deux mois ça le problème tu dis
c'est que vous êtes devenu rapidement
plus complices que cam en quoi c'est
quoi cette phrase qui dit le beau et la
splendeur durée quand le monde est à
l'endroit mais nous on se mettait dans
la tête à l'envers pour pouvoir marcher
droit justement pas mal ouais
un jour c'est là un peu trop loin et là
tu dis c'est devenu moins drôle quoi bah
ouais on a le problème si moi c'est
qu'on a ce côté
enfin elle comme moi quoi donc tous
confondus à se côtés jusqu'au boutiste
ouais
forcément ça peut nous desservir aussi
quoi vous êtes un peu brûlé les ailes
tous les deux quoi mais on se faisant du
bien
un vignes vraie passion l'un pour
l'autre non ouais c'est la merde sens
sacré sinisant way la rupture avec kool
shen
ouais quand on quand on vient d'une cité
on a tous cette envie en eau des d'en
sortir
surtout de discret son contexte que de
sortir un peu de tout ça même si les
façons de portant soir jeudi rock quand
on a grandi à une cité on on peut pas
changer a toujours quelque chose et ce
qui reste gênant peut on peut essayer de
parler autrement de maquiller tout ça il
ya toujours il ya toujours une espèce
d'acuité qui reste un paria plein de
choses quoi et moi j'ai eu l'impression
que contiennent la machine arrière quoi
c'est à dire que nous on habite dans une
cité lui dans une résidence et que à un
moment donné il avait un petit complexe
au niveau de ce à quoi
ouais alors que enfin pour moi ça jamais
tes deux médailles quoi un jour été a
dit j'ai envie d'arrêter j'ai une vie de
famille je veux voir ma meuf
je ne vois jamais ben ouais il me dit ça
au moment où moi moi là la fille avec
qui je suis
doch amoureux
grâce à elle je danse liberté et puis
tout le monde me regarde comme comme une
bruch
donc je suis demandé ce qui l'habite en
australie ou en france quoi parce que
c'est quand même au courant ce qui va
arriver que qui viennent je comprends
qu'il a envie aussi d'avoir une vie à
côté parce que il en avait une de toute
façon quoi qu'il arrive juste à mon ami
ça c'était s'était pas vraiment la libye
qui fait la raison je pense qu'à un
moment il aurait peut-être pu être plus
fondue connaissent surtout qu'en plus la
veille on se parle au téléphone etc en
fait c'est on se voit demain pour voir
ce qu'on va faire pour le prochain album
et du jour au lendemain le mec me sors
j'ai envie d'arrêter
moi ça fait 15 ans que je fais ça à un
moment donné tu ne sais plus faire que
ça et puis de toute façon c'est à la
base moi je reproche pas le fait qu'on a
envie d'avoir une vie à côté mes en
train de vivre une aventure on n'a rien
demandé on tomber là dedans par accident
on remplit des stades ont enfin on n'a
jamais demandé tout ça ce qui est
intéressant dans le bouquin c'est de
voir comment vous complétez tous les
deux dire que lui il avait ses petits
cahiers et les créditer bien ces petits
trucs biens propres
ça tu foutais le feu sur scène ouais
ouais ouais ouais il faut pas comparer
sur ça ça mais c'est vrai que les vaches
n'ont plus de l'artiste when i là il a
besoin de savoir où il va alors que moi
j'arrive encore à aujourd'hui aviron
quant aux gens le jour quoi alors que
lui
ouais ça paraisse apparaît impossible
quoi pour lui aujourd'hui tu as une vie
de famille toi ouais il va comment
mathis alors il vaut mieux merci ça va
le mourre ça va mieux que ce matin ouais
d'accord si affaires unités à bout de 30
ans
est ce que comme toutes les filles de 30
ans vous avez marre des coups d'un soir
mais bon temps en temps un mec c'est
bien aussi
moi j'ai trouvé l'homme de ma vie donc
les coups d'un soir ça ne regarde plus
comme toutes les filles de 30 ans j'ai
un ami gay pour vous accompagner dans
les magasins un mickey mérite aux heures
et lieux comme toutes et tous les trente
ans vous avez un ami gay pour vous
accompagner dans les magasins je ne sais
pas pas particulièrement des copines un
ami c'est con cette question est ce que
comme toutes les filles de 30 ans une
expérience avec une copine
non ça t'emmerde bah oui qu'est ce que
tu fais c'est pour le prochain album ça
mais j'adore les hommes
est ce que comme toutes les filles de 30
ans vous attendez une demande en mariage
comme on attend le bus non non c'est
comme toutes les filles de 30 ans j'ai
déjà tout essayé en amour et en sexe
c'est la même question tout à l'heure et
tu tourne toujours autour du sexe ça
devient énervant
derrière ce que je peux dire qu il ya
des chansons aussi sur l'ennui sur la
boulimie sur la politique lors lui
pendant 16
et toujours ce sujet comme toutes les
filles de 30 ans vous adorez parler qu
avec vos copines en bouffant des sushis
j'adore ouais au bouffon quoi des sushis
ouais ouais ouais disqualifie de 30 ans
elle mange des sushis dans cette
tendance c'est ça c'est une question par
dû vous poser est ce que tout comme
toutes les filles de 30 ans tu veux
répondre bah alors je vais te les faire
à toi alors bien sûr comme toutes les
filles de 30 ans joey vous n'envisagez
pas d'amour sans un cunnilingus avant
deep et à rennes je fabrique les images
est ce que comme toutes les filles de 30
ans je vous commencez à vouloir éteindre
la lumière avant de faire l'amour a
surtout pas monter comme je suis surtout
par j'ai envie qu'ils aient peur
pourquoi
c'est vachement important pour moi joey
est ce que comme toutes les filles de 30
ans et à votre top sexuellement mais
c'est déprimant ne pas en profiter et
finalement tu vois c'est déprimant ce
que j'en profite pas effectivement est
ce que comme toutes les filles de 30 ans
joey vous êtes t'acheter un sextoy pour
les longues soirées d'hiver service que
je t'ai produits à temps si tu fais
savoir comme je te remercie alors écoute
non mais en parler ils l'assurent les
c'est comme toutes les filles de 30 ans
vous rappelez des sexes les soirs de
déprime
moi quand je déprime diable est tout
seul ouais et c'est comme toutes les
filles de 30 ans j'avais prévu une
liposuccion cet été écoute
je commence à prendre un peu de brioches
et pourquoi pas vraiment temps que j'ai
le jeu de jambes ça me dérange pas un
brin donc pas besoin de liposuccion est
ce que comme toutes les filles de 30 ans
vous pensez que le botox finalement
c'est pas mal mais où
fort bien
est ce que comme toutes les villes de 30
ans et 10 à vous rentrez le ventre quand
vous êtes à poil avec un mec moi j'ai un
ventre très plein avant et voir prend le
livret va page et tu fais à mon ventre
est ce que comme toutes les filles de 30
ans ou fait semblant d'être heureuse ah
non mais non justement je dis toute la
vérité rien que la vérité je le jure
maintenant ah oui mais lente et cache
quoi il est comment ce mec alors celui
qui est responsable de la transformation
il est comment
[Musique]